bonjour catherine bonjour à tous coûte
que l'arrière de patrick dils lors de la
troisième audience de son procès en
révision
le meurtrier présumé de deux enfants a
accusé un policier ne lui avoir extorqué
ses aveux valérie ermite l'ex-inspecteur
varlet il restait près de quatre heures
devant la cour d'assises son témoignage
était l'un des plus attendus de ce
procès c'est lui qui a recueilli les
premiers aveux circonstanciés et patrick
dils aujourd'hui très contreversé pour
la première fois de sa vie
patrick dils atria partie l'enquêteur
expliquant avoir avoué par lassitude
pour en finir avec la garde à vue et les
pressions psychologiques mais surtout la
plus en de lui avoir suggéré dicter ses
aveux ce cas une nouvelle fois
longuement nier le policier puis la juge
d'instruction il ya douze ans lors du
premier procès la police accusé dérouler
ses certitudes aujourd'hui son enquête
est examiné à la loupe par la justice la
cour d'assises de la marne chargée de
juger patrick dils ne veut visiblement
laissé aucune zone d'ombré dans ce
dossier